let me pull up the story here we got
this from nbc washington uh ian just
mentioned a moment ago dc mayor requests
national guard to help with migrants
bust to capital
a lot of people are laughing about it
saying it's like it's irony it's funny
or texas and arizona's plan is working
let me tell you something texas and
arizona could be bussing the migrants
back to where they came from to their
home countries sending them to d.c is
helping the democrats in the bite
administration with their immigration
agenda
they are basically saying
so texas is like we're going to send
these migrants to you dc and then dc is
like thanks for the help we're going to
then distribute you know these people
around the country where we see fit what
this means places we don't live it's
true
the way it's supposed to work you get in
line and say i'd like to come to this
amazing country we say let us figure it
out and give you the best possible place
so that everybody thrives what the
democrats and the bite administration
are doing is they're saying
just let everybody come in and then
we'll sort them out later no rules no
rules rules and then texas and arizona
are like we'll show you biden we'll
actually pay for the buses to send them
into the country
and then people are laughing about it
and i'm like dude you're just helping
them
they have texas and arizona could more
easily it is it is a longer bus ride to
dc i feel like people on the right are
being duped into thinking that plan was
a good plan
there's a few things i'm not so sure how
it applies here but i know when i was
covering migration issues in europe one
thing all the migrants would do is they
would destroy their passports before
coming in and touching ground in any
european country because they had
basically been told well if you don't
have a passport they don't know where
they can deport you to
and so there are some tactics that
migrants will use to try to prevent
deportation so i'm not sure how
difficult it is for these states to do
that
if they are trying to apply legally to
get in but don't have standing
it would be much easier to deport them
but then if they're going in and like
claiming asylum status there still has
to be some sort of court case which is
the problem because they still have to
be held somewhere our goodwill is being
taken advantage of yeah people who are
coming here are not asylum seekers
they're economic migrants
i get it i i'll tell you this i have
infinitely more respect for them for the
than the modern american leftist that
hates this country but there still has
to be a process for the sake of
maintaining what this country is if it's
good and i mean our economy is not so
good these days but still better than
other places well then there's a reason
why it is because there's a system in
place if people just come in just start
ripping apart that system you know it's
the decline of empire i mean actually
wasn't the roman empire dealing with uh
immigration
it was the it was the fall of the empire
it was all the northern uh tri like i
don't know who was it the uh not the
vandals people in the northeast but
basically
after the the empire had spread all
throughout the eastern and the western
roman empires the the empire split in
half they but then it just like over the
next 200 years people just kept pouring
across the border and then they would
set up their new government like their
foreign government in rome in the roman
territory then all of a sudden you
realize it's not roman territory anymore
because it's that other government is
now
running the show rome also had like
bureaucratic complexity that wasn't
sustainable past a certain point and
part of that is that sound familiar yeah
and kind of what you're talking about
like when you're saying the culture is
part of what holds people together
that's that's like the story it's the
agreed-upon story it also lends into why
at first you don't need to hire
mercenaries because the story is strong
and people believe it and then after a
while when you get a certain critical
mass of burn it down this this place
doesn't you know people in the country
disrespecting the story of of the very
country or the nation that's when it
starts to come apart is when the belief
that this is even a good thing that
we're upholding
and then what you were just mentioning
about like at the beginning of the
nation
how many bills were being passed well it
also feels like
that the constitution was there to say
like this is what the government is and
and that's it
right and then it just kept growing and
growing and growing and then a lot of
people they need to secure their you
know position
so
keep passing bills keep making your job
position relevant so that complexity
grows
not because i believe in it and i
believe what this this you know uh
nation could be but a lot of it is
self-preservation so it builds this
bureaucratic bureaucratic complexity
that just can't
sustain for very long a lot of people
are commenting saying i'm wrong states
don't have the authority to deport
people only the federal government does
but i kind of uh
i don't i don't know how that makes
sense i mean i i i accept that i may be
wrong on that i just mean like the
states have to have the ability to be
like you just illegally entered turn
around and go away you know what i mean
i mean i guess but biden doesn't seem to
care about it so
if you're i mean look carrie legs talk
at the very least i'll put it this way
fine maybe they can't legally
but couldn't they just
anyway i don't know i don't understand
well they're getting steamrolled by the
federal government on every single level
i mean even before
migrants are entering texas they are
getting cash-based interventions from
the un whose number one funder is the
united states and their government right
so american tax dollars are going to
funding migrants trip from south america
and mexico up to texas illegals trips
they're handing out these cards in
reynosa at migrant camps debit cards
from the u.n so that they can make it
there you can look this up on the center
for immigration studies it's a real
thing your tax dollars are directly
going to funding a legal migrant's
journey up into texas okay hold on hold
on you know ian you talk about the fall
of rome a lot right and it seems like
what happened with rome was that
migrants started coming in
what if our adversaries studying that
said here's a way to destroy a country
started funding
mass migration but but the us is funding
it the us are the number one you know
funder to
organizations like the un who are giving
the money the migrants so why are the
u.s destroying themselves i don't
understand that's a great question and
and like is the u.s a singular thing
anymore or is it or is it an organism
attacking itself why is tim smiling like
that
because i'm i'm seeing all the comments
people are making about bucko
and it's just hilarious sorry i mean
he was getting this like ominous smile
like he knew something i'm petting the
cat while smiling like
you're scared
people are posting like emojis and stuff
in in the chat and making jokes about
bucko
she's very pleased yeah so bucko doesn't
seem to care enforcement officers cannot
arrest someone solely for illegal
presence for the purpose of deporting
them because it is a civil violation
didn't they have a something in place
where during covid they could like turn
them right around though
yeah so there was title 42. yeah but
they got biden got rid of that i don't
think yet i think court blocked him he's
trying to
we should hire mercenaries on the state
level to remove base
here's what i'll say though you know to
people who are saying that we can't
deport them okay well i'll say this
wouldn't they be better off being
detained or or something or uh
in some way
organized in such that we can
try and reduce crimes try and stop
criminals try and vet them in the
natural process like what i mean is if
we catch a bunch of illegal immigrants
our duty is supposed to be like okay
like let's figure out who you are what
you're doing here and go through that
process
why just send them to dc
the bite administration has been
smuggling children trafficking kids on
military aircraft around the country
it just feels like you're paying half
the bill for them because they're that's
what they're trying to do
now they're gonna call the national
guard and it's gonna take more taxpayer
dollars their attitude is probably like
oh we don't care about that like you're
sending migrants to us okay
we we we think them calling an emergency
is something bad for them but they're
probably just like cost of doing
business
um
was it okay wait i'm like looking this
up to make sure the story is real but i
heard that
israel was doing like re-migration where
they were paying people to go back to
their home countries for a while
i heard that denmark is doing that
because they actually do want to
encourage people to go back to wherever
they came from denmark is
doesn't really want a lot of immigration
to their country i guess they've really
been overwhelmed but it's denmark saw
what was going on with sweden with those
grenade attacks
denmark knows what's up yeah it's crazy
so when i was covering the sweden stuff
we were staying in copenhagen for a
little bit
and when you're going into sweden they
stop you and they check your ids
because they're worried about
the people who are coming out of sweden
there was the a few months before i had
gone there someone threw a grenade onto
a balcony killing an eight-year-old
english tourist oh i heard that yeah
grenading was a huge problem i don't
know if it still is but it was a huge
problem several years ago it still is
my wife is dutch and she's i mean he's
been seeing it for years her and her
family is that the the immigration waves
um it's really like the cohesiveness
that you would have had in these
neighborhoods before
starts to come apart the story you know
that that binds them all together starts
to come apart and um it's interesting
because also holland uh and and several
other places out there is where the
thing with the farmers
is
shooting at them right you know we're
about to run out of food so the best
thing is to uh stop farmers from doing
their job it's almost like it's on
purpose zubi called it a controlled
demolition yeah that's what i mean if
you listen to catherine austin fitz and
i know i mentioned her on this um show
before
she worked under george w bush um in the
um
in the 90s i think doing hud or
something like that but she said she
started getting some of her peers
telling her that the united states is
over we're moving assets to offshore
accounts um and we need a bunch of
forward-facing like public-facing events
that will have the public not looking at
what the real perpetrator was
so she was she's been saying this for
years and she's probably one of the most
coherent speakers on the topic as you
can get and she was even saying with the
blm riots i think i might have mentioned
this before it was like 34 out of 37
of the riots happened within
like a just a very small perimeter
around the central banks there and her
theory was
you know well it just makes it
convenient that like all this territory
can be built up as the smart grid which
is what the whole push is so build it up
as the smart grid buy up this you know
what do you mean paw shops the
infrastructure destroying the businesses
and creating crime which drops property
values so they can be bought up and
turned into a smart grid that's what she
says like i wouldn't go so far as to say
that you know but i mean i wouldn't deny
that that might be an angle but this is
katherine austin fitz you know having
worked under george w bush
i'm sorry herbert walker bush in the 90s
saying that she's been tracking like
where did that well over 21 trillion
dollars of the the federal budget go you
know she's the one that's been tracking
all that so she was the assistant
secretary of housing and urban
development for housing under george w
bush
i saw a joke on reddit some guy was
saying when my rent prices start going
up i'll just go out into the
neighborhood and fire a couple shots off
to uh lower the housing prices
where it's like uh some guys like i
rented the department heard a gunshot
ran outside and the guy in the next door
said not to worry about it it was him
they just tried to keep the property
about the rent prices low yeah yeah yeah
that's it oh so i just want to confirm
because i i don't want to put fake news
on the tim cast right israel did have a
policy where they were um
giving financial aid to african
countries to send back african refugees
and migrants
they weren't even sending them back to
their home countries they were like
screw it just a place in africa rwanda
retreat will work we'll give you aid so
like if israel can do it why can't we
just
give you a bit of support we're sending
them all back
send them all to puerto rico i wonder it
doesn't matter
i wonder if it can be solved because as
strict as trump was we still saw a
massive influx of migrants the caravans
all that stuff
you know trump trump was very serious
build the wall deport him you got to go
home you can come in legally all that
stuff and during his presidency we had
videos of people charging border guards
like migrant caravan running full speed
and attacking u.s borders it's happening
every day when i was i was just down
there in december and what's going on is
like you drive on the highway from
tapachula up to northern mexico you're
gonna run into a caravan every 20
minutes i'm not even joking but what's
going on is they'll block the highway to
try to get buses north and they'll
pressure the government oh these are
major shipping routes if you don't give
us a bus you're not you're basically
your country is not going to be able to
function so they'll get them buses but
what will happen
is then those buses will start to
transfer to come and get the caravan and
another caravan will block those buses
on the way up and then they'll have to
negotiate with those guys and it's just
absolute chaos there so when i make
jokes about oh we need to just start
deporting people and do this
we honestly do need some sort of policy
that is a yes or no open or closed
because it's actually destroying every
country in between it's destroying
mexico it's destroying the lives of
these people who have no idea what the
actual immigration system is in america
is there an immigration system i'm
seeing my cousin my nephew everyone get
in by walking in and when i apply
legally i can't get in so i guess that's
just how the u.s works i'm going to do
that everyone's life migrant refugee
mexican american is getting destroyed by
no clarity on this issue
it's really really harsh reality because
if you just say don't come in
and then they do it anyway
what do you do you arrest them and then
you deport them and then say please
don't come back and then they come back
and you're like what do you do like at a
certain point we're being attacked i
know right
so the the cost of either integration or
repatriation is extensive for us
we have to pay for planes we have to pay
for buses we have to pay for border
guards for police for first places where
these people can stay we have to pay for
medical treatment for their children and
they just keep coming i'm like we got a
serious problem that's not being dealt
with thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you